we're asked to compute 347 divided by
five so let me just rewrite it like this
we have we have three hundred and forty
seven three hundred let me write it
bigger we have three hundred and forty
seven and we want to divided by we want
to divide it by so I'll put the division
sign here maybe the long division sign
depending how you want to view it
divided by and then I'll put the five in
blue divided by five so the first thing
we do is say does 5 go into three no it
doesn't so let's add another digit here
does 5 go into 34 well 5 times 5 times 6
is equal to 30 so that goes into it and
if we go above that five times seven is
equal to 35 so that's too big so it goes
into 34 6 times because if we didn't
went with seven we've gotten 35 that's
too big so five goes into 34 6 times 6
times 5 is 30 we saw that right over
there and we subtract 34 minus 30 let me
do this in a new color 34 minus 30 will
four minus zero is 4 3 minus 3 is just
zero and then we can bring down this 7
here 5 goes into 40 7 how many times
well let's see five times 5 times 8 is
equal to 40 so that would work let's see
if we can go in even more times 5 times
nine is equal to 45 that'll work that's
still less than 47 and then we have 5
times 10 is 50 so this is too big this
is too big so we want to go with 5 times
9 is equal to 45 or five goes into 47 9
times 9 times 5 is 45 and then you
subtract again 47 minus 45 is 2 and then
we're done there's nothing else to bring
down here and well one day we'll learn
about dividing it into decimals and
getting some kind of a decimal
representation but we're not going to
worry about that right now we have
nothing left to bring down so 5 33
47 divided by five is 69 it is 69 it is
equal to 69 but it doesn't go evenly
into 347 there's something left over
there's a remainder there is a remainder
right here so it equals 69 and sometimes
you'll see it written as remainder 2 or
sometimes it's a capital R sometimes
people will write out the word remainder
so 5 goes into 347 69 times but you're
gonna have two left over or another way
to think about it is 5 times 69 is 345
so you're always gonna have two left
over in this circumstance so that is our
answer